>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Robert Salazar: Good
afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
Today's presentation, a book
talk about "This Chair Rocks,"
a manifesto against ageism
by Ashton Applewhite,
is presented by the Library's Office
of Equal Employment Opportunity
and Diversity Programs.
Today's guest, Ashton Applewhite,
didn't set out to become a writer.
She went in to publishing
because she loved to read.
And, according to her, because
she didn't have any better ideas.
She had a weakness for the kind of
jokes that make you cringe and burst
out laughing at the same time.
Her boss kept telling her to write
them down and the collection turned
into the bestselling
paperback of 1982.
She was a clue on the
television game show "Jeopardy."
Who is the author of
truly tasteless jokes?
The answer?
Blanche Knott.
Her pseudonym.
And, as Blanche, she made
publishing history by occupying 4
of the 15 spots on the "New
York Times" bestseller list.
The first woman to ever do
so, if I'm not mistaken.
First person?
Incredibly impressive.
Her first serious book,
"Cutting Loose,
Why Women Who End Their Marriages
Do So Well," was published
by Harper Collins in 1997.
"Ms. Magazine" named it or called it
rocket fuel for launching new lives.
Since 2000 she has been on
staff at the American Museum
of Natural History where she writes
about everything under the sun.
The catalyst for "This Chair
Rocks" was puzzlement, as she says.
Why is our view of late
life so [inaudible] grim
when the lived reality
is so different?
She began blogging about aging and
ageism in 2007 and started speaking
on the subject in July
of 2012 which is also
when she started her blog
"Yo, Is This Ageist?"
During that time she has
become a Knight Fellow,
a "New York Times" fellow,
a fellow at Yale law school.
And she has written for
"Harper's," "Playboy,"
and many other publications.
And she has been recognized
by the "New York Times,"
National Public Radio
and the American Society
on Aging as an expert on ageism.
Her book, "This Chair Rocks,"
a manifesto against ageism,
was published earlier
this year in March.
Ladies and gentlemen, please help
me in welcoming the wonderfully
and honestly humorous and
incredible author Ashton Applewhite.
>> Ashton Applewhite: Thank you.
I never -- I never open with my full
bio except I was going to today,
but then Robert beat me
to it because I was going
to tell my unorthodox
literary career starting
with all the publishing
companies that turned down
"Truly Tasteless Jokes" before
it was a phenomenon, well before.
It was called "What's the Difference
Between Garbage and a Girl
from New Jersey, the
Book of Tasteless Jokes."
And my two favorite declined notes.
Simon and Schuster
said, "Publish this?
We can't even Xerox this."
And Viking Penguin said,
"If we publish this,
the little bird would have to hide
its head under its wing in shame."
But then Ballantine
published it and it went
on to make publishing
history of a sort.
I -- This isn't in the bio.
I am responsible for "The New York
Times" bestseller list introducing
the other and how to category
because Barbara Tuchman
and other fancy schmancy
editors at Random House felt
that Blanche was besmirching
the bestseller list
and they invented a
separate category.
That is true.
And so then Harper Collins
published my divorce book
and then 20 years later I
wrote -- I don't like writing.
I like the thinking part,
but not the writing part.
So I wrote this and submitted
it to Harper Collins.
And they turned it down because no
one else was writing about this.
And a lot of other publishers turned
it down and I didn't want to sell it
for a little bit of money so
I ended up self publishing.
So this is a self published book.
And I just want to
tip by hat to Roberto
because you could have
knocked me over with a feather.
There was a profile of me in
the "Washington Post" that some
of you may have seen and that's --
He told me today that
that's what he saw.
But that was just a few weeks.
The book was just three weeks old.
So thank you everything, Library
of Congress, for taking a chance
on a book that no one had
heard of which is getting
out there in a really nice way.
The reason I wrote this
book in hindsight was
because I was afraid of getting old.
And I didn't know that
was the reason,
but I started a project inspired
by my mother-in-law who was
in her eighties at the time.
And she said, "Why
don't you write --
" She's a bookseller,
she and her husband.
And she said, "Why don't you write
about something people
ask us all the time?
So when are you going to retire?"
So I thought, "Well,
that's catchy and it's,
you know, upbeat and optimistic."
And the blog at the
time, the first one,
was called
sowhenareyougoingtoretire.com.
And I started interviewing people
in their eighties and nineties
who were working and they were
amazing and they were a dime a dozen
which -- neither of
which surprise me.
But I also started reading and
researching about longevity.
And what I learned so soon and
so easily just knocked me over.
I mean again and again.
Like, for example, I
thought the odds of ending
up in a nursing home were,
you know, pretty good.
And it turns out that the percentage
of the American population over 65
in nursing homes is
4%, down from 5%.
It's dropping steadily.
And that people were happiest at the
beginnings and ends of their lives.
It's called the U curve of happiness
and it's incredibly well
substantiated independent
of class all around the world.
The older people get,
the less afraid of dying.
I mean I won't bore you with more
statistics, but I just thought,
"Why don't people know this stuff?"
And we don't know it because we live
in a culture that drowns out all
but the negative about
life after 65.
And the reason behind
that writ large is
because if aging is a problem then
they can sell you stuff to fix it.
And if aging is a disease then
they can sell you stuff to cure it.
And it's not curable.
It's not fixable.
It's not a problem.
It's not a disease.
It's a natural, powerful
lifelong process.
And I wanted to tell that story.
And of course then suggest
that we call out the voices
that frame it as decline alone.
So I'm going to start with
a definition of ageism.
The formal definition
is discrimination
and stereotyping on
the basis of age.
And we're ageist whenever we behave
towards someone or think differently
about a person or a group on the
basis of how old we think they are.
And it's not a household world or
a sexy one, but neither was sexism
until the women's movement turned
it into a howl for equal rights.
And, as with all ism, stereotyping
lies at the heart of ageism,
the assumption that all
members of a group are the same.
It's why people think everyone in
a retirement home is the same age.
That would be, "Old."
Even though residents
can range from people
in their fifties to centenarians.
So imagine.
Can you imagine anyone
thinking that way
about a group of people
from 20 to 60?
Right? And the older we get the more
different from one another we become
because we age at different rates,
physically, socially, cognitively.
So that's why doctors say if you've
seen one 80 year old you've seen one
80 year old.
Like racism and sexism, ageism
is a socially constructed idea
that has changed over time
and that serves a social
and economic purpose.
It's not about how we look.
It's about how people in power
assign meaning to how we look.
And unless we challenge
stigma, we reproduce it.
We experience ageism any time
someone assumes we're too old
for something.
A task. A relationship.
A haircut.
Instead of finding out who we
are and what we're capable of.
Or if someone assumes
we're too young.
Ageism cuts both ways as when people
complain about lazy millennials or,
say, "Kids are like that."
Now I see ageism everywhere.
When old pals cringe
at public mention
of how long they've
known each other.
That's my old pal Judy
[inaudible] me her in ninth grade.
Instead of savoring
their shared history.
>> And what year was that in?
>> Ashton Applewhite: Oh,
you're going to make me do math?
I was 15. Can I just
say how old I am?
That's easier.
I'm 64. When men and women
feel compelled to lie
about their age on
online dating sites.
When people bridle at being
kindly offered a seat on the bus.
On billboards, on television,
in hospitals and hotels,
over dinner and on the subway.
"At age 80, who doesn't
need a facelift?"
A poster announcing a subway
station renovation asked brightly.
That was on the [inaudible]
New York where I live.
In the incessant barrage of
messages from every quarter
that consigns the no longer
young to the margins of society.
In our mindless absorption of
these messages and numb collusion
in our own disenfranchisement,
I've learned that most
of what I thought I knew about
the aging process was wrong.
That staying in the dark serves
powerful, commercial, and medical,
and political interests
that don't serve mine.
And that seeing clearly
is healthier and happier.
So my instructions are to be wonky.
I'll start out being wonky and
if I'm too wonky you can --
So here's really interesting
information
which really surprised
me when I learned it
that links ageist stereotypes to
our physical and mental health,
that actually attitudes towards
aging affect how our minds
and bodies function
at the cellular level.
A growing body of fascinating
research documents the link
between people's perceptions of
aging and their health and behavior.
Yale psychologist Becca Levy
has been measuring the effect
of age stereotypes
for close to 20 years.
Over and over she and her
colleagues have found that people
with more positive feelings
about aging behave differently
as they age compared
to those convinced
that growing old means
becoming useless or helpless.
Long term studies show that
positive attitudes towards aging are
associated with better functional
health and more predictive
of health status than socioeconomic
status or race or gender.
That's really interesting, right?
Implicit interventions.
Flashing positive age stereotypes
in the form of words like active
and creative on a screen so briefly
that you just absorb it subliminally
improved not just self perception,
but physical functions like balance.
People with more positive views of
aging do better on memory tests.
They have better handwriting
which correlates with good health.
And they can walk faster.
And they recover more fully
from complete disability,
severe disability.
And they live longer and not
just a little bit longer,
an average of seven and
a half years longer.
Those unable to overcome a
lifetime of internalized ageism,
on the other hand, were less
likely to seek healthcare
or to exercise, and died earlier.
A goal of public health and aging
policy is more healthy years,
not years without health.
Imagine the benefits to
health and human potential
of overturning ageist stereotypes
before they distort self image,
shorten steps and limit prospects.
Think what overturning
ageist stereotypes would do
to extend not just the lifespan, but
the health span of all Americans.
There will be -- I'm going to
leave plenty of time for a Q
and A after this because there's
also really interesting data
about attitudes towards
aging and cognitive function.
So feel free to ask me about that.
And also -- And my favorite study in
this vein was they took two groups
of college students and with
one they did the same flashing
of messages with words
like -- I love the choice.
Florida and bingo were
two of the words.
And then with the other group
they either used neutral messages
or positive messages.
And what they measured in the
test was the fact that the group
of college kids that had received
the negative messages subliminally
walked to the elevator more
slowly than the other group.
And those, you know --
Those are 18 year olds.
So imagine we get a lifetime of
messages about, you know, debility
and other, you know, ugly
things, what that does --
To the point at which they do
actually have the potential
to become self fulfilling
stereotypes.
Okay. The -- So how about the myth
that older workers take jobs away
from younger ones which is a
fallacy called the lump of labor
that economists have
debunked countless times?
When older workers stick around,
it does affect the upward
mobility of younger workers.
It is not easy to balance legitimate
seniority, the greater knowledge
and experience of older workers,
with the ambition of younger ones
to rise through the ranks.
Instead of working toward
equitable solutions, though,
companies exploit the problem by
pitting older and younger employees
against each other as early
twentieth century manufacturers did
with workers of different races
or nationalities and as Walmart
and Amazon do today with
union and non union employees.
In an ageist and capitalist society
where corporate profits come first,
those tactics go unchallenged.
The problem is structural
which these tactics
deflect attention away from.
High unemployment rates aren't
a too many old people problem.
They're a labor market problem.
The amount and nature
of work is not fixed.
Otherwise the expansion
of the female workforce
in the twentieth century would have
put hoards of men on the streets,
for example, but it didn't.
If the job market is strong, a big
if, workers of all ages benefit.
Having more salaries
generates more tax revenue.
Seasoned talent is valuable.
And it's not a zero sum proposition.
Older people are job creators.
According to a 2012 Pew
charitable trust report, quote,
"Evidence suggests that grater
employment of older persons leads
to better outcomes for the young.
Reduced unemployment.
Increased employment.
And higher wages."
Unquote. It's not only that
older workers don't crowd
out younger ones.
They also increase employment
among the young in many ways.
As bigger earners, they can buy
more products produced by the young.
They may be business owners
who employee younger workers.
And of course they pass
along valuable skills.
An aging population also means
unprecedented opportunities
for innovative kinds of jobs
that involve intergenerational
collaboration.
Older workers are typically
better at seeing the big picture
and can draw on institutional
knowledge, especially in a joint
like this, I bet, while youngers
likely have an edge when it comes
to seeing what's new and
integrating technology.
Pitting workers against each other
also fails the common sense test.
It's not as though our lives
and financial obligations are
contained by generational moats.
Children inherit.
Grandparents exhaust their
savings or help with tuitions.
A Social Security check
makes everyone
in the household more
financially secure.
People with steady incomes
help unemployed family
and friends stay afloat.
Independent of age and biology,
tribes and networks support us all.
And now a little rant about
one of my least favorite terms
which is agelessness which you
see being touted, you know.
All sorts of things are
just going to keep ageless.
Like anti-aging, I'm not
going to read the bit.
There's a wonderful British
writer named Anne Karpf
who wrote a terrific
book called "How to Age."
And, you know, aging is living.
Living is aging.
So think about that when a product
touts its anti-aging properties.
And she said, "You can no more be
anti-aging than anti-breathing."
So offering neutral
ground, an end run,
around all these messy
ambiguities, agelessness sounds
so seductive, doesn't it?
On a tube of eye cream agelessness
promises to erase the trace of time.
In pop culture it describes
people who stay young
in their fifties and sixties.
In gerontology it suggests
that a youthful spirit can remain
unaltered within an aging body.
None of these scenarios is
possible and they're all ageist.
As sociology Molly
Andrews has argued, quote,
"The current tendency towards
agelessness is itself a form
of ageism, depriving the old of one
of their most hard
earned resources."
Their age or years, right?
Rather, this is agefullness,
an accretion of all the
things we've done and been.
Not catalogued or curated,
but stored random access
within our bones and brains
that makes us who we are.
Hag. Spinster.
Crone. Old fogy.
Old fart. Old goat.
Little old lady.
Dirty old man.
Sweet old thing.
Geezer. Biddy.
Codger. Fogy.
Coot. These stereotypes are ours
to reject or subvert on the way
to more compelling and accurate
aspirational identities.
At the moment I'm leaning
toward hag,
something a driver actually
called me last year when I banged
on the trunk of his
car after he bombed
through the pedestrian crosswalk.
Hag. Outside of Shakespeare, really?
Maybe it was my funny fake
fur cat hat that undid him.
I wish I were young again.
People say this all the time.
When pressed, however, few would
actually move their game pieces back
to the beginning of the board
or anywhere close unless they
could transport their present day
consciousness back in time as well.
Adolescence again?
No thanks, even though I'd get
to have more time with Judy.
I'd love my 18 year old cartilage
back, but I dance more now
because I'm less self conscious
and I prioritize better.
Whatever our trajectories,
however we've navigated loving
and letting go, whether children
or houses or dreams, we are the sum
of those experiences and
what we learn from them.
They make us us.
That is agefullness, rich
and deep and invaluable.
So this is from a section
called "What Makes it
So Hard to Ask for Help?"
In this country no myth
is more powerful than that
of rugged individualism,
the notion that success
and independence are
paired and that relying
on others signals not just physical
frailty, but weakness of character.
That myth serves us poorly,
especially people with disabilities
and older people, to
increasing overlapping circles
in the Venn diagram of life.
Dignity and freedom of choice are
and remain critically important,
of course, yet the way we grow
old is governed by a whole range
of variables, including
environment, personality and genes,
compounded by class, gender,
race, luck and the churnings
of the global economy over which
we have varying degrees of control.
What happens when we
can't hoist a big suitcase
in to the luggage rack anymore or
drive at night or drive at all?
When we can't hear the
instructions anymore
or read the directions
or understand them?
When we can no longer
make it to the bathroom
or even heave ourselves out of bed?
A culture that idealizes self
reliance amplifies those anxieties
and silences questions about
the structures that strand us.
Where's the low luggage rack?
Why no large print or audio
assist or person to ask?
Why should diapers at the end
of life be any more shameful
than at the beginning?
This culture demands
optimism without end,
downplays life's challenges
and shames us
when inevitably we fall short.
This ethic of individualism serves
the proponents of small government
who conveniently ignore
the role of services paid
for by their fellow citizens
in making many of them wealthy.
This ethic has systematically
eroded communitarian values
and sanctioned the U.S. government's
abdication of responsibility
for its vulnerable citizens.
The effects can be seen in
decades of concerted efforts
to shrink the wealthier state
and public assistance programs
even though exactly the opposite is
called for if the country is to meet
the enormous challenge of caring
for its older citizens
in the years to come.
As long as those challenges are ours
to shoulder alone, there's no point
in addressing or even identifying
any of the larger factors
that make it hard for people
to navigate the transitions
of late life.
Consider the terrible story
of the Crabtree family.
Jim Crabtree's wife developed
early onset Alzheimer's at age 56.
For six years Crabtree's
parents were able
to watch her during the day,
but his 84 year old dad was
experiencing cognitive problems
and his mother, 80, suffered
from severe arthritis.
In May 2013 Crabtree's
father shot both women
and himself while his
son was at work.
Crabtree told NBC's Maria
Shriver that it was a great gift
from his father since it,
quote, "Ended my Alzheimer's
and elder care issues at once."
And since the three who
died were all ready to go.
He loved them, you know.
He was devastated, but
that's how he saw it.
NBC's only comment was
that care giving is tough.
What does that say
about our society?
Imagine an alternative scenario.
Decent, affordable healthcare,
subsidized care giving,
and help from a team of social
workers, friends and neighbors.
That support would
have gone a long way
to help Jim Crabtree's family cope
and spare them this horrific end.
His mother's only illness
was arthritis.
Stories like these have even healthy
middle aged people wondering whether
suicide or, say, triple murder
will be the ethical alternative
to asking for help.
These are lethal forms
of internalized ageism
and they handily serve the American
government's twenty-first century
austerity program.
I just imagine this like lightening
bolt coming over from the capital
and like smiting me at the lectern.
But got to smite back.
And let's see.
Just one more.
The call to action.
Although we age in different
ways and at different rates,
everyone wakes up a day older.
Aging is difficult, but few
of us opt out and the passage
of time confers very
real benefits upon us.
By blinding us to those benefits
and heightening our fears,
ageism makes growing older
in America far harder
than it has to be.
That's why I've embarked
on a crusade
to overturn American culture's dumb
and destructive obsession
with youth.
As I've gone on this journey
from the person to the political,
it's become clear that
ageism is woven deeply
in to our capitalist system and
that upending it will involve social
and political upheaval.
Ageism, unlike aging,
is not inevitable.
In the twentieth century
the women's movement
and the civil rights movements
woke mainstream America
up to entrenched systems
of racism and sexism.
And a digression here is that all
change starts inside each of us
and that's why the tool
that catalyzed the women's
movement was consciousness raising.
Women came together and compared
notes and realized in the process
that issues that they had been
thinking were personal problems,
whether it was, you know, not being
respected at work or, you know,
tying it all to their
material status in the world,
that this was -- that these
were not personal problems.
These were widely shared
political problems
that required collective action.
And that's, you know -- All of us --
You know, getting older is not easy.
There are real challenges and
we need to deal with them.
But the way it's framed in
the culture now is, you know,
"You're not doing a
good enough job."
Or, "It's your fault if you can't
-- " You know, if you have wrinkles
or you can't, you know, date --
find someone to date or whatever.
And while those are our problems,
they are widely shared
political problems also.
Right? So we need to come
together and talk about that
and mobilize against
them as a group.
More recently disability
rights and gay rights
and trans rights activists have
brought ableism and homophobia
and transphobia to the
streets and the courts of law.
It is high time to add ageism
to the roster, to include age
in our criteria for diversity.
Duh. And to mobilize against
discrimination on the basis of age.
It is as unacceptable as
discrimination on the basis
of any aspect of ourselves
other than our characters.
If marriage equality is here
to stay, why not age equality?
If gay pride has gone
mainstream and millions
of Americans now proudly
identify as disabled,
which is an amazing transition
in this society where physical
and cognitive perfection are
so prized, why not age pride?
Right? Aging is an accomplishment.
The only reason that
idea sounds outlandish is
because this is the first
time you've encountered it.
It won't be the last.
Longevity is here to stay.
Everyone is aging.
And ending ageism benefits us all.
This book is a call to wake up
to the ageism in and around us,
embrace a more nuanced
and accurate view
of growing older, cheer
up and push back.
What ideas about aging have
each of us internalized
without even realizing it?
Where have those ideas come from
and what purpose do they serve?
How do they play out across our
lives, from office to bedroom,
in muscle, in memory, and what
changes inside us once we perceive
these destructive forces at work?
What might an age friendly world,
friendly to all ages,
that is, look like?
What can we do individually
and collectively
to provoke the necessary
shift in consciousness
and catalyze a radical age
movement to make it happen?
I hope you will join me.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Uh oh.
>> Congratulations
on the great turnout.
>> Ashton Applewhite: Thank you.
>> I have to say that I'm
in charge of a senior and --
aging and senior culture
area of studies
and professional organization.
We can talk later.
And I have a good -- you know,
a good challenge in
getting people to --
>> Ashton Applewhite: Yeah.
People think aging --
>> Not sexy, but you're
making it sexy.
>> Ashton Applewhite: Thank you.
>> Okay. And I'm so glad.
I'm so glad that you're [inaudible]
how you think of ageism mostly
with older people and of course
maybe the prejudice is mostly there.
>> Ashton Applewhite: We
are all in this together.
Everyone was young.
Everyone's going to get old.
>> But okay.
And everybody goes
through different ages,
but I can't escape the
age cohort that I'm in.
I'm a Baby Boomer like you are
and I don't think I have
all those characteristics.
And how injurious are
these gen X categories,
millennial categories and so on?
And silent generation.
Thank god.
I know people from the silent
generation who are anything but.
>> Ashton Applewhite: Shocker.
>> Yeah. And so I mean,
you know [inaudible]
so that's how they [inaudible].
How injurious are those?
How useful are those terms
and how do we combat them?
>> Ashton Applewhite: They're -- I
mean they're useful demographically
and obviously, you
know, I too use them,
but you know if any generalization
about an individual on the basis
of their age is, you know,
inherently problematic and if,
you know, stereotypes are always
wrong, but especially in the case
of age because the older we are the
more different from one another --
So obviously a tribute,
a characteristic,
to an entire generation is
absurd, although clearly there are,
you know -- We listened to
the same music growing up
and there are certain -- I mean
there are certain legitimate,
you know, characteristics
that can be attributed to us.
The bigger problem with it, though,
and it is something I touched
on in the work thing, is that it
is an attempt to frame the issue
in terms of scarcity, in terms of
zero sum, in terms of conflict.
And as long as it's old versus
young -- And it's bee, you know --
This thinking has been debunked
in countless fields
by countless experts.
It pits us against each other
and deflects our attention away
from the actual issue whether in
the workforce it's that, you know --
It's the way the job
market is structured.
In care giving I don't
want to be stuck with,
you know, caring for old people.
I mean there's -- So that's
the problem with it really is
that implicit in it
is the assumption
that the generations are
pitted against each other.
And we really need
to think radically
in the broadest possible terms
about how to meet the challenge
of an aging population because of
course the people who are now 20,
30, 40 are going to benefit from it.
Here's another example.
It's why I say all age friendly.
You know, when they frame it as
we have to do this expensive stuff
to help poor pathetic old
people get up the stairs,
ramps also help people on crutches.
Ramps also help women with strollers
and men with strollers and people
on skateboards and -- Right?
So this -- And ditto
in the workforce.
You know, flex time and
making buildings accessible --
People of all ages and anyone
trying to balance work life,
anyone with any kind of care
giving responsibilities, yes,
those accommodations benefit
older workers disproportionately,
but they also benefit
people of all ages.
So really try and push back.
Oh, and here's another thought.
Sorry. Really long answer.
But when we think of it in
generational terms it's --
We often talk about allocating
resources by age and you see this
around healthcare all the time.
We have enough money to
help newborns, but you know,
whey does that old guy need
a sixteenth hip replacement?
Well, you know, if
they botch my first 15,
I'd like a crack at the 16th.
I would. But here's
the larger point.
Don't get sucked in to that
argument like I just did.
We no longer accept the idea
of allocating resources by race
or by sex and it is no -- not any
more acceptable to do it by age.
Period. Yes?
>> [Inaudible] is that I'm realizing
as someone who sits all day
at my job that I'm
not even as mobile
as my 80 year old [inaudible].
So [inaudible] when you're
talking about ramps and all that.
I feel like I'm going to
need all these things.
>> Ashton Applewhite:
You probably will.
We all will.
>> I was wondering, using the terms,
do you think with the
Baby Boomers aging --
Will that get more people involved
in the cause to help the rest
of us coming behind them?
Because like when I [inaudible]
and saw all the old people still
with their families, getting
around, I was like we don't do that.
But then if my dad [inaudible] I
would have to be taking care of him
and trying to go to work.
So.
>> Ashton Applewhite: I mean that
is a colossal, colossal question.
You know, of course.
And one -- I mean when
I was floundering,
which I was for a long time,
trying to figure out what my way
through this topic was, at one point
I woke up in the middle of the night
and bought the domain
name botharetrue.
Seriously.
Because you can argue, you know,
with regard to the Baby Boom,
you know, the good news is I think
most of us are getting old enough
to realize we're actually
going to get old.
And some of us will be radicalized.
And I'm really hoping
that those of us who --
You know, I grew up in D.C. and I
remember, you know, the big marches,
the -- You know, the anti war stuff.
So -- And people a little older.
I missed part of the
women's movement,
but my talks are almost
always attended by more women
and I think there's a lot of
women who learned about sexism
and who can apply what
they learned to ageism.
So I'm hoping, you
know, that we mobilize.
On the other hand, there is, you
know -- The counter force is, oh,
well, we're Baby Boomers.
We're special.
We're healthier than ever.
We are -- You know,
we are somehow exempt.
And that if we, you know, eat
more sushi, do more, you know,
sit ups, we can escape it.
And that is age denial and that's
what a lot of the -- Or I mean okay.
AARP. Thunderbolt.
But you know that is their message.
You know, there's no gray
hair in their magazine.
There's no talk about disability.
There's no talk about
people over 70.
You know? And we need to embrace
the whole kit and caboodle.
We need to do it, you know,
from the full age spectrum.
So, you know, when you go to
Honduras, see what works there
and see what you can do
to bring it about even
in just your family
life or your community.
And I mean there's a ton of energy.
Yes. The short answer
to your question is yes,
because the Baby Boomers are aging
a ton of resources are pouring in.
Some of them progressive.
And some of them just
looking to make money.
I mean now that federal prisons
can't be for profit anymore,
guess what those guys
are investing in?
For profit nursing
homes, for example.
>> So in terms of ideas for building
their movement and action plan,
it seems one of the reasons that
this may be more urgent than ever is
because the supreme court basically
eviscerated the older worker's act
and legalized age discrimination.
So where the actual points?
Who are the people who are working
on building the movement and,
you know, what would be the next
step in terms of building that?
>> Ashton Applewhite: I've
never built a movement before.
There are -- I mean
I'm speaking tomorrow
at a conference called The Positive
Aging -- Positive Aging Conference.
>> It's an international
conference on positive aging.
>> Ashton Applewhite: There we go.
Thank you.
It's at the capital hill
and I'm sure you could
show up if you wanted.
I mean I met a fellow from
London just before I came
down who started this group
with a colleague called
The Age of No Retirement.
There are lots and lots of people
coming together on this and one
of the ideas -- And there's
going to be a meeting at part
of the positive aging thing,
a sort of smaller meeting,
sponsored by the National
Council on Aging
to answer exactly that question.
I will throw it back at you to say
if you know anything about this,
do what you can to make it happen.
It's going to take all of
us and, you know -- And I --
Sorry to sound like a shill, but
I really urge you to get people
to read my book because
it's really persuasive.
Indeed you have [inaudible]
attending the conference.
So.
>> [Inaudible] Ashton's
book, and I --
>> Ashton Applewhite: Oh, god.
I didn't pay her to say this.
>> [Inaudible] public never met
her before, is that for all of us
who are working out there -- I'm an
elder care anarchist and when I say
that everybody goes, "Gasp."
But, you know, you have all
these grassroots people,
all these people who have a vision.
But because of you being gutsy
enough to sit there and say, "Hey,
I didn't get a publisher and
this has to be published,"
you've created a focal point.
You created a gathering point.
And I'm trying to remember the
name of the group in New York.
>> Ashton Applewhite: Oh,
the radical age movement?
Yeah. I mean that's
another grassroots thing.
But I mean I'm one focal point,
but this is my proxy, you know.
There's thousands of those.
And so I don't want
to be the focal point.
I want there to be
10,000 focal points
and honestly I don't know what form.
I mean I know some
stuff that we need.
I mean we need clearing houses.
We need an association.
But it is really happening.
Yes. In the back corner.
And then the woman in front of you.
You in the blue shirt?
Yes.
>> Thank you.
I'm just wondering what your
research has shown about, you know,
sort of I think a common fear
of getting older is
dementia and Alzheimer's.
What can you say about that?
>> Ashton Applewhite: Well, for
one thing, no one knows that rates
of Alzheimer's have
dropped precipitously
in the last few decades.
The absolute number of people
with Alzheimer's is growing
because the percentage of
people of the population
who are old is larger,
but the chances
of any one individual
getting Alzheimer's have
diminished significantly.
So the real epidemic is anxiety
over memory loss which you hear.
And every time -- I mean I used
to think senior moment quips
were kind of cute, you know.
They were self deprecating.
And then finally it dawned on
me that when I lost the car keys
in high school I didn't
call it a junior moment.
And that every time you make
a joke like that you reinforce
to whoever you're making
it to, and to yourself,
that cognitive decline
inevitably accompanies aging.
20% of the population escapes
cognitive decline entirely.
We all know some of those
super sharp 90 year olds.
Right? Most of us will lose
some processing function,
especially the thing where
you can't remember the name
of the movie you saw with
what's her name at that place.
But the main picture is most of
us don't lose much more than that.
You know? It's just like -- And
the physical decline is inevitable,
but most of us remain able to do
some version of the things we love.
The really interesting
thing about Alzheimer's is
that there are a bunch
of long term studies
and results keep coming in now.
When people die they autopsy them.
The brains of the some of the people
who were completely
sharp were filled
with Alzheimer's type [inaudible]
and what those people had
in common is a sense of purpose,
a positive attitude towards aging.
So, you know, this ties back
to what I think is a
really compelling argument.
So anyone out there in public
health or who knows anyone
in public health, an
anti ageism campaign
as a public health initiative
is a really smart idea.
And -- Because if you --
I mean what's the main obstacle
to having a purpose in late life?
Structural discrimination
that sidelines older people.
So let's work on that.
And I hope that answered your
question and now the woman there.
Yes. Can you speak any louder?
>> I was listening to something
the other day on the news
and you can tell that healthcare
is really starting to discriminate
against getting older because in
a lot of states now [inaudible]
because of that they don't
[inaudible] the thing
that Medicare and -- Medicare.
And so you have all these issues
where now you have to almost look
at what state you go
to for your healthcare
because your particular
insurance company may be pulling
out of that piece.
So then you're going to get
discriminated against because --
with healthcare because
that has created --
A really great thing about
the preexisting conditions.
And so you have to almost look at
what state you retire in to look
at the healthcare system and
what insurance company --
>> Ashton Applewhite: Yeah.
It's a problem.
You and then you and then you.
So -- But the gentleman
in the corner.
>> In terms of coalition building,
I wonder if you heard the term TAB.
>> Ashton Applewhite:
Temporarily able bodied?
>> Yeah. Offered by the disability
community just to remind people
that it's a normal part of life.
>> Ashton Applewhite: Yeah.
I mean we have a ton to learn from
the disability rights movement.
And their fantastic motto which
is "Nothing about us without us."
And make sure that
in every group you're
in that there is age diversity as
well as other types of diversity.
Yes.
>> I thought it was
kind of interesting
because last year I was comparing --
>> Ashton Applewhite: Temporarily
able bodied is what people
with disabilities call
the rest of us.
Sorry.
>> I was comparing long term
health insurance policies
and an insurance company agent came
to our house and said the number
of -- the reason for long
term health insurance is
because of dementia or
Alzheimer's [inaudible].
>> Ashton Applewhite:
50% or so of the people
in nursing homes do have
advanced dementia, higher maybe.
>> And so she said,
"So if you decide
to take this particular policy,
it's likely you'll get a call
from the insurance company and in
that call they ask you some
questions and at the end
of the call they'll see
if you have any -- "
>> Ashton Applewhite: If you
remember who you're talking to.
>> Right. But so I got the call
and the first question was what
was today's date and that --
Like every single day I
look at my phone or --
>> Ashton Applewhite: I never
know what today's [laughs].
>> What day it is until I --
You know, or can't remember.
But I've been doing that all
the time so I thought, "Gee,
I hope I get the insurance."
Because, you know -- But anyway.
But that's what they said,
that the number one reason
for long term healthcare --
>> Ashton Applewhite: That's true.
Funny you should say because I just
applied for long term healthcare
and they did the whole
thing and they did the quiz.
And they turned me down
because I have osteoporosis.
Yeah. Right?
That's -- What was [laughs].
I mean and I sort of
tried to appeal.
It's like, "This really puts me
at risk of institutional care?"
I know. I'm going to try and figure
out how to make noise about it.
Yes?
>> Hi. I'm Kate [inaudible].
>> Ashton Applewhite: Oh, hi Kate.
>> [Inaudible] we are a global
organization that's looking
at the issue of aging
all around the world.
But I wanted to just touch on the
thing about a public health campaign
on ageism because you're in luck.
The national day of older persons
[inaudible] is on October 1st.
The theme this year is a theme
on ageism and countering ageism.
The folks [inaudible] through
the World Health Organization,
but different organizations
around the world
that will be kind of
carrying this theme.
And we'll be doing
something here in the U.S.
>> Ashton Applewhite: Yeah.
It's the theme for
the United Nations
and I'm giving the
keynote at the UN.
Did you know that?
Yeah. Thank you.
It really -- But -- And what I'm --
I'm trying to think if I can get
away with the title there, you know.
Confront ageism or
the rest is noise.
I probably need to do something
a little less in your face.
But it's really true that whether
you have expertise in Medicare
or nursing home administration or
housing policy or workforce policy,
if we don't look inside
between our ears at our own --
you know, the ways in
which we are ageist sort
of counter intuitively -- Right?
Not for evidence that we're
not, but at the prejudice
that we have all internalized
over a lifetime.
I catch myself saying and
thinking ageist stuff all the time.
It's ongoing and we haven't
had any counter messages
in the culture until
really recently.
But -- So that's essential.
And then whatever field
of expertise you have --
And then once you start to see it,
it's like a genie getting
out of the bottle.
You see it everywhere.
And then you can bring
that awareness
to whatever your expertise is.
If we don't take that initial
step, all we do is Band-Aids.
We really just do short fixes
without addressing the
structural discrimination.
You know, you can eat all the sushi
you want if you can afford it.
But it doesn't help the fact
that you can't get a job.
You know? That shit
is discrimination.
You and then you.
>> I'm just curious because
thinking about comparing ageism
to all the other isms I come
from a marketing background
so the biggest thing is, you know,
having other people who aren't
in your group understand
your experience
or that they care about
your movement too.
The main thing about ageism is
that everybody has the experience.
So I'm just wondering if you
have thought about that at all
and maybe it's kind of touching on
your -- I forget the term you used,
but aging indifference or --
>> Ashton Applewhite:
Old person in training?
>> Well, it's just like in denial.
Aging denial.
Is there aging denial that's keeping
people from really embracing --
Because it's not like it's just
helping this small group of people.
It's everybody hopefully.
>> Ashton Applewhite: Right.
I mean age -- Age denial is
the heart of the problem.
As long as we pretend we're
not getting older, you know.
And then, you know we celebrate
the ability to change and adapt
through life until we
hit late middle age
and then suddenly the goal
becomes to like put on the brakes
and have everything stay the
same which is, A, crazy, and B,
not doable, and, you know, punitive.
The weird thing about ageism is
that of course is affects everyone.
And I -- It's really important
I think always to point out.
Of course it disproportionately
affects older people,
but it also affects
young people, you know.
It's really hard to be in your
twenties and one of the things
that makes it harder is this
message like, "Peak life right now."
If you're not, you know, building
that career and having awesome sex
with someone really beautiful
every night, downhill from here.
So, you know, I mean that sucks.
And that is ageism.
So it's really important to point
out that these forces
affect our whole life.
And another way I've been
thinking about it a lot, and I --
is that this whole idea of --
you know, that diversity
is important I think is
critically important.
And so is this idea of, big
word alert, intersectionality
which was a word that came
out of black feminist studies
which when a scholar named Kimberle
Crenshaw realized that racism --
The civil rights movement
didn't address gender issues.
The women's movement wasn't
addressing race issues.
Well, all these forms of oppression
intersect and reinforce each other.
So at the UN we're going to
be calling for a convention
on the rights of older people.
And what I want to say is, you
know, there is already a convention
on the rights of women,
on the rights of children,
on the rights of people
with disabilities.
If you [inaudible] a convention on
the rights of other people, you --
Most older people are women.
It affects children too.
And we, many of us,
age in to disability.
So when we combat ageism, you know,
we make the world a better place
to be female and to a be a
person of color and to be,
you know, all those other things.
So I think -- Does that
answer your question?
I think that's the meta
message is it does affect you.
It affects you now.
And whatever your personal
issue happens to be,
there's a way in which it is --
I mean, you know, are the people
in your movement of all ages?
You know, is one thing to look at.
And who was -- Yes.
>> You had mentioned
earlier that the numbers
of Alzheimer's patients
has gone down.
>> Ashton Applewhite: The incidence.
They don't know.
They don't know why.
And so other things.
Like there was a big -- It was a
big piece in the "New York Times"
about the incidence of old age.
It's on my Facebook page which is
This Chair Rocks Facebook page.
And -- Oh, and I should say it's
available in all electronic editions
and in an audio book read by me.
But if you -- But I put a ton
of interesting research
up on my Facebook page.
Also my blog is
thischairrocks.com/blog
or you can just go to it.
And all my research is
searchable so it's all there.
You can write me.
Ashtonapplewhite at
Gmail or I'm easy to find
since I'm the only
person with my weird name.
And also there's a
free downloadable guide
to starting a consciousness
raising group around age bias
which is how I met my friend Alberto
who lives here called, "Who, Me?
Ageist?" And it draws
on, you know, the --
sort of the way the women's
groups were structured.
And gives questions
and resources also.
Yes. Okay.
How are we doing?
Last question.
>> I'm very impressed
with your eloquence
and I was wondering what is
your educational background.
>> Ashton Applewhite: It's
even lamer and weirder
than my [inaudible] publishing.
I'm under educated.
I have no degrees.
Well, I did go to the National
Cathedral School for Girls
which was hideous, but
I learned to write.
I wanted to do my homework.
I learned to focus.
And then I went to
the Kirkland College
which is the coordinate
college at Hamilton
which got eaten by Hamilton.
And that's all the school I had.
I'm a completely auto whatever.
>> DIY.
>> Ashton Applewhite: DIY.
Autodidact.
Kind of. Yeah.
Thank you all for coming.
I hope -- I'll be over there.
Thank you.
>> Robert Salazar: Please take
advantage of the opportunity
to purchase your book for
$18 and Ashton will sign it.
Plus here I've got another
round of applause for you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.